what this group is in effect are hard
core al Qaeda fighters who have
associated themselves the Syrian group
Javad them Laura they've traveled from
Pakistan predominantly in Afghanistan to
Syria to find themselves a safe haven
what was really surprised me when I was
watching during with the Syrian air
strikes i was watching the American
media and they accepted this Khorasan
group as being factual nobody said well
where has this group come from who are
they suddenly they were a bigger threat
than I saw there are more immediate
threat than ISIL this thing is is that
this isn't a name that's in existence in
within jehadi circles there's no flag
that groups can rally around there's no
philosophy there's no manifesto there's
nothing that would suggest that they are
a terror group in the mold of ISIL in
the mold of al Qaeda this seems to be a
manufactured term about a month ago we
were told that this was a group that
posed a huge threat to the u.s. we
weren't given any more details than that
now this was something that the kind of
piqued my interest because I'd never
really heard of this group before when I
started speaking to intelligence experts
they were telling me well this was a
term that we used in house it was a term
that we decided the fitted where these
people come from it's not what they call
themselves want more download the aj+
mobile app and join the conversation
available in your app store now